how would you like to become
much more productive
if you're selling sell more if you're
producing produce more if you're
creating create more
well i'm going to share something with
you that i learned a long time ago
and it has to do with time
i was having breakfast with earl
nightingale
he was on a speaking engagement that i
was going to with him
and he said how would you like to meet
for breakfast well of course
like that i was on it
and i always had a half a dozen
well-prepared questions whenever i met
with earl well this one day
um i said to him earl i said how did you
master time management
he looked at me and he said what are you
talking about
well i said you accomplished more in a
short period of time than anybody i've
ever seen and i've never seen the guy
rushing i never seen him even walking
fast
well he said first of all i didn't
master time management nobody masters
time management he said time can't be
managed
he said you can only manage activity
he says i just carry a list in my pocket
and i every night before i go to bed i
write down a half a dozen goal achieving
activities that i will start working on
tomorrow and when he said i get up and
get dressed and get to work i start on
number one and he said i don't go to
number two until number one's complete
when number one's complete i forget it
and i go to number two
and i focus on number two when number
two is complete
i forget it i go to number three
and i said that's it he said that's it
i started to do that you know i found i
could become much more productive
you see a lot of the things you're
spending time on don't even have to get
done
i learned a long time ago
that
some things get done through neglect
you're going to do them you were
supposed to do them you never did them
never made any difference
see a lot of the stuff we do it's
useless it's not productive it's just
busy and it's busy for busyness sakes
what we want to do is learn how to get
things done but get things done that
really make a difference
and when you do that you're going to
find your productivity will jump
as your productivity jumps
your rewards will jump
see the people that are in the most are
the ones that produce the most you say
well that doesn't always work that
always works
it may not work as fast as you think it
should it may not work the way you think
it should but i'm going to tell you
something this is an orderly universe
everything happens by law
everything
you'll always get what you deserve
nevermore nevertheless it balances
itself out over time
become more productive
how do you become more productive
write down your goal achieving
activities that you're going to do
tomorrow before you go to sleep and when
you make up that's where all of your
focus goes and you don't let people
distract you
people come up have you got a minute
what they're really saying is let me
waste about 15 minutes of your day or
maybe an hour
say no i'm sorry i don't have a minute
i'm busy i'm focused
you're going to find your productivity
we'll go up
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and learn the seven
habits of insanely productive people
enjoy
habit number two have a friday finisher
list with brendan burchard having my
friday finisher list
what does that mean it means like you
know i've got a list here of the things
that have to happen
by friday it's my friday finisher list
it means that monday when i go to work i
am aware of all the things i need to get
done and complete by friday and that's
what i use at united time called a week
four is making sure i get all these
things done by friday i know that by
friday
5 p.m or whatever time i want to finish
working on friday that these list of
deliverables have happened and they are
done and they are complete for the week
and if i can stay on track with that
oh my gosh
the the year just proceeds so much more
effectively how about number three let
go of grudges with greg mcewen
simplifying your state i think is a is a
huge return on investment if you can let
go of a grudge
if you can let go of something that you
keep on
you
know draining you
then you have there's just more of you
on offer and that's not through
grinding effort that's through just
removing burdens you don't have to be
hauling up the mountain at all right
you know the number two area is
effortless action that's effortless
state the first thing that's one
effortless state so you're simplifying
all of your your basically all that
clutter that's in your mind yeah so it
makes it easier to focus on what matters
one of the things that i've learned is
that specifically on grudges is that we
need to learn
like we have to ask an unusual question
about grudges and that is
what did we hire the grudge to do
yep as clayton christensen says with any
product or service that you have
you don't you don't
you don't no one wants a six you know a
six uh
inch drill bit what they want is a six
inch hole right yes you you there's a
reason that you're hiring that product
or service well you can do the same with
grudges
every grudge we hold
we hold for a reason we've hired the
grudge to do something for us maybe we
hire the grudge
to make us feel powerful see i am i am
one up i'm above that person see they
did this bad thing i'm holding on to
that see i'll show that i'm superior we
hold on to it for a sense of superiority
or maybe we hold on it uh because we
like that we get to tell a story of
being a victim and people go oh yes we
get sympathy for doing it well we hire
grudges to do certain jobs and what i
think is that if we simply evaluate
grudges like
we say
how are you doing in your job
performance for me
are you actually protecting me are you
actually making me powerful are you
actually getting people to build a
stronger relationship with me or if you
evaluate them and in the book there's a
section specifically one by one you can
do this
where you you say well is you actually
find well actually it's not making me
powerful it makes me more vulnerable
uh it makes me vulnerable with everyone
because i'm carrying this wound still
and not letting it heal
is it is it helping me to build
relationships no if you pay attention
you notice that when you tell these
stories
you kind of have to find new people to
tell them to because people get bored of
it right and so you're not building
deeper trust relationships you're you're
actually kind of wearing them out along
the way
and you can go one by one to suddenly
discover that this is like a bad
employee
we have a grudge is like you've hired
them to do this they aren't doing any of
those things they're using you grudges
use you they burn you up they waste you
out they make you weaker
and so just through this process you
start to find like i'm ready ready to
fire my grudges
ready to be free of it so that i can
actually recuperate whatever the
percentage is sixty to seventy percent
with jit with tim
maybe it's different for other people
get all of that back
and we can start putting that into the
stuff we really wanted to do in the
first place even though you would never
think of forgiveness as a productivity
hack
like maybe no one's ever written that
you know the productivity hacks
is to forgive people in your life and
yet what else can you call it if you
could get back that much energy that
much of your own
light and ability and capability it's
the best rebate available there's a
story that i came across in the research
that i love of a man who was productive
in his community and one day he he saw
what he thought was a piece of string on
the ground and it was a piece of string
he gets it he's like oh i can put that
to use he puts it in his pocket on that
same day in the marketplace someone else
had lost a wallet
and lost some money
and they thought that they had seen him
pick up the wallet and take it
accused him of it publicly there was no
way for him to prove his innocence
and so the word went out this person has
acted dishonestly dishonorably and so on
now at this point in the story he has a
choice he can't prove his innocence but
he could have in this moment let go of
the
accusation of the harsh judgment and he
would have suddenly had all that energy
back to be able to get back onto well
what can i do something about how can i
serve how can i make a contribution how
can i be successful again but he doesn't
he gets fixated on it everywhere he goes
he talks about it he nurses the grudge
he explains it's a piece of string don't
you see it was wrong a piece of string a
piece of string people started laughing
about this guy all he ever wants to talk
about is a piece of string and it makes
him ill and on his deathbed final words
of the story you know a little piece of
string a little piece of string and this
is how the story goes
now that is it's a fictionalized account
but it it illustrates the point of where
are you putting your mental energies
if we put them on grudges if we put them
on things that have happened we wish
they hadn't happened or even on our own
mistakes where we go i wish i'd been
different we're beating ourselves up for
past mistakes we're just we're just
putting tons of effort onto things that
will exhaust us and burners out instead
of moving forward to the things that
really matter so just also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four learn to say no
with james clear i'm reading an article
you wrote
that resonated with me and i don't know
that this gets worse as maybe you
achieve more
but you're like the ultimate
productivity hack is saying no i felt
this very acutely after atomic habits
came out and over the course of the next
the first like three months that it was
out i was doing okay and then the book
really started to take off and i was
constantly feeling like i'm a very slow
learner and that i should have been
upgrading the level of which i was
saying no to things and i was always
like two or three months behind i was
always on the hook for more stuff than i
should have been and it was because i
was saying yes too many things
and there's this weird dynamic where
success starts to eat itself so
the the thing that was getting me all of
these opportunities is because i was
focused and i wrote a good book and
because of that people were very
interested in talking to me or sharing
these new ideas and like there's all
there's all these interesting new
opportunities that come your way you
know do you want to speak at this thing
or what about these tv rights or how
about this interesting opportunity or
would you like to come to this you know
cool conference or retreat or whatever
and individually each of them sounds
really fun and interesting but
collectively if you start to say yes to
all those things you don't have any more
time to do the thing that got you those
opportunities in the first place which
is thinking clearly and writing a good
book and so
success like eats itself all these new
opportunities come in and they squeeze
out the thing that you were good at in
the first place
so
it's a i don't know the other thing
that's difficult about it and i still
you know i'm close enough to the
beginning of my career that i can still
appreciate this and feel this
for the first decade of my career i was
trying to say yes to everything i was
trying to capitalize on every
opportunity so that i would have the
chance now to say no to basically
everything because you got a bunch of
stuff coming your way so at first it's
like outbound and you're trying to like
capitalize on every opportunity you can
and then there's this like rapid switch
where now all of a sudden everything's
inbound and you have to put up a tight
filter and uh that can be a difficult
lesson to learn habit number five
schedule your time with dean graziosi i
want you to think about scheduling time
see what we do is we
we say i'll get to that next week or
i'll work on that new project tomorrow
or i'll work on that project at lunch
time but then when we work on it we
dabble you know the
the greatest gift i could give you is
have a start time and an end time to
everything and anything that you do
right because what happens is we get
excited about something we want to make
more money so we get a course we get a
program we get something and then we
just
we don't we decide maybe tuesday maybe
thursday after work and then a week goes
by a month goes by schedule the time a
start time and end time
schedule when you're going to be done
with the project or when you're going to
commit to doing it how about number six
get rid of overwhelm with mel robbins i
am going to disappear overwhelm using a
simple picture mason jar and a garden
variety spiral notebook i know i'm not
kidding i'm actually going to disappear
overwhelm overwhelm is something that
you want to fight because if you allow
yourself to stay in a state of feeling
overwhelmed by the amount of things that
you have to do that pressure and that
uncertainty combined with this feeling
that you can't get anything done is
going to create anxiety in your life
it's going to impact not only your your
well-being but it's also going to
severely limit your ability to focus and
get things done so the most important
thing with overwhelm is to understand
what it is and a simple tool that you
can use to get rid of it so here's what
we're going to do so let's pretend that
this right here this empty mason jar is
your brain in order to do your best
thinking you need to make sure that
you've got the full capacity of your
brain
leveraged and pointed at the things that
are important to you here's the problem
when you go through life as you go
through life what happens is you know
your brain starts to fill up with
information and that's what creates a
state of feeling overwhelmed being
overwhelmed is nothing more than having
a full brain so as you go through your
day-to-day life and you start checking
email and looking at texts and looking
at facebook and sitting in meetings and
flipping through television channels and
sending uh emails and writing excel
spreadsheets and uh running and picking
up the kids at work and getting another
text and looking at instagram and
looking at twitter and checking out the
news
your brain gets pretty full doesn't it
and so when you feel overwhelmed what i
know about you is that your brain is
full of a bunch of garbage
and so uh oh i didn't think about the
drain draining i hope that's not
bothering you but it's certainly going
to bother me what you need to do
in order to fight overwhelm is you've
got to actually do a brain dump
you got to get rid of all that stuff so
that you've got an empty brain so you
can focus again so how do you do that
it's easy to do with a cup of water
because you just pour it out this is
what you're going to do you are
literally going to dump out everything
that's in your head onto this piece of
paper every concern every worry every
to-do every thing that's bothering you
that you're thinking about you're going
to write down
[Music]
all right and when you're done writing
down everything that's in your head and
there's absolutely nothing left oh
i've got something due tomorrow that i
kind of forgot about um once you get
that stuff all done on a piece of paper
pull out a highlighter
take a look
you could do everything on this list you
could
but what should you do what are three
things just three that you should do
in order to advance the things that
matter to you
let's see i gotta do that one
i gotta do that one and i gotta do that
one
the rest of this list
is complete and other garbage it's other
people's stuff it's the email stuff it's
the meeting stuff it's the stuff that's
not all that important to me it's not
that mission critical so by dumping
everything out
i now not only have the three things i
need to do
i've got a clear head so i can get it
done inhabit number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
get into airplane mode with marie forleo
put your entire life on airplane mode so
don't try and ignore your phone or
ignore the emails or ignore the slack
messages or whatever else that you have
that dings and rings and pops up that's
like me telling kuma to ignore this
slice of salami ain't gonna happen
who can't ignore the salami
who can't ignore the salami
so rather than resist temptation just
eliminate it and that means you have to
put your entire life on airplane mode
now obviously turn off all the
notifications so close all the tabs
close all the windows turn off the apps
and especially for your phone i suggest
just turning the damn thing off
however you also gotta shut off some
people too and that means that you might
have to tell your kids
and your spouse and your co-workers that
for the next two hours or one hour or
three hours that you don't exist kind of
like this
see
nobody here
burnout is real but i think most burnout
happens because people are not doing the
thing that they actually love doing it's
not just about being busy and keeping
your mind occupied all day you can be
busy and hate your life and get burnt
out if i was an accountant
i would hate my life and burn out in a
day because i don't like being an
accountant but doing this thing that i
love i put in way more effort way more
work and i love it it's been 10 plus
years of still having my youtube channel
and i'm not burnt out if anything i'm
pushing harder than ever before because
i love it and so i think it's not just
about being busy it's about being busy
on the thing that is your mission for
life now compassion fatigue is a thing
doing it so much that you burn out
yourself is possible but again that is
not why most people are burning out most
people i believe are burning out because
they're spending too much time too much
energy too much effort doing things that
they hate and if you wake up and hate
your life and hate the job you're about
to go to then there's no wonder why you
feel like you're burning them so i
recently came back from going to tony
robbins event in dallas he invited me to
sit in the front row and i'm super
blessed and grateful to have tony
support and i went there with alex
friend of the channel who helps me run
trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there alex
is flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a tony
robbins event it's it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever i travel
is actually meet believe nation meet you
guys
and so all through the event i wear my
believe hoodie and i'm not wearing grand
stuff i'm wearing evan carmichael stuff
with the plane and the believe on the
back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning of
every event saying hey i have some
friends of mine you might know them
don't be celebrities leave them alone
don't talk to them let them have their
own experience
and it always makes me sad when he says
that because
for me
meeting you guys meeting people who
recognize me and that's a group that i
over index because people who watch tony
videos you know they're probably gonna
find my content
i like it i like it more when people
come and say hi it adds to the
experience for me and then on the last
day before we rushed out to go to the
airport i set up a meetup right i had an
hour open before having to get to the
airport so let's do a meet-up let's do a
local dallas richardson texas meetup
right and and it could have spent the
time doing something else or sleeping in
or writing my book or doing anything
else but
it's not burnout for me like that fuels
me that gives me more energy i love it
hanging out with believe nation gives me
more energy than it takes away and then
took an uber to get to my to the airport
and the guy who drove in the uber was
actually in the the meetup in
richardson's like i got to leave early
because i got to start my job okay great
and then i booked an uber and there he
is
total fluke but amazing and so
it's a lot of work you know i was all
day all night
not connecting with my team not doing
the things that i'm supposed to be doing
and i still make time to be with people
and and make a one hour meet up
because that hour was open
and
it fuels me
but if it was something that i hated
just that half an hour just 15 minutes
i'd start to feel like i'm burning out
like i don't want to be here this is
terrible and so i think it's really
important that you're doing work that
you love that would be a burnout for
other people but not a burnout for you
because you love it so much so how do
you find it how do you find the work
that you love i got a three-step process
called who i how i'm going to talk about
it in depth in my next book but let's do
a super quick analysis here to help you
guys who might be struggling step number
one is who so you're who is your most
important core value what is your most
important core value as a human being
mine is believe it's the one word most
important value for me so when you
figure out what it is that you stand for
as a human you can then look at your
life and see where you're falling short
if you are unhappy with life
it's because you are living
incongruently with your most important
core value so someone whose core value
is freedom as an example
you can look at your life like are you
allowed to be free are you free at work
are you free in your relationships are
you free you know in these different
areas if not then you're not going to be
happy that's why you're not happy
because your boss doesn't allow you to
have freedom mine is believe so believe
has to be in everything that i touch if
there's a situation that's lacking
belief i'm not going to be happy with it
so that just gives you already an
indication of who you are and starts to
make sense of your life going backwards
and allows you to plan it better going
forward so it's one of the most
important exercises i think anybody can
do figure out what your who is who i
have step two is why so why is your
purpose your purpose comes from your
pain your purpose comes from the deepest
darkest most painful moment in your life
whatever that was your purpose is to
help other people who are currently
going through that thing whatever you
struggled with suffered with endured
felt like you never want to wish that on
your worst enemy never want to go back
and experience again that pain that's
what i'm talking about you want to help
other people who are currently going
through that pain because there's a lot
of people who are currently going
through that thing
who you were x number of years ago
there's a lot of people who are
currently like that right now that's who
you want to help for life that will
never get old that's your purpose for
life i want to help entrepreneurs for
life i believe in entrepreneurs for life
because i struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and i want to make the path
a little bit easier for everybody else
so that's your why and your who and your
why are constant they never change your
core values and your purpose are for
life and that's amazing the last step is
how who i how how is your passion how is
how you got out of the pain that you're
in so you struggled with something how
did you get out of it you may not be
fully out of it maybe you're still on
your journey out of it but you're
further ahead than you used to be
how did you get out of it did you read
books did you watch videos did you
meditate did you walk your dogs did you
listen to music like how did you get out
of it how did you get out of it and that
is a recipe that you can teach other
people how you got out of it was not
some random one-off situation you can
teach other people so i struggled a lot
with my business i felt worthless as a
human i wanted to quit i told my partner
that i quit how i got out of it was
modeling success i looked at bill gates
how he started microsoft and i applied
those strategies to my business and we
started to see some success
20 years later what am i doing still
modeling success right i want to learn
from grant i want to learn from steve i
want to learn from kanye i want to learn
from these people it's why i keep
creating this content
how i got out of it was studying success
and now i teach other people how to
study success
right how you actually go about doing it
may change
when i first started doing it 20 years
ago is through books right now it's
through videos and in 10 years 20 years
is going to be through vr and a bunch of
other technologies that i'm sure are
coming but
the how you got out is a teachable
recipe that you can give to other people
so if you're struggling with burnout
and you think it's because you don't
love the work that you're doing and you
know that you're destined for something
greater that you do have michael jordan
level talent at something but you don't
know what it is and you want to figure
it out figure it out this is this is the
process this is the easiest process i
know of to get there figure out your who
your one word most important core value
figure out your why your purpose comes
from your pain and figure out your how
which is your passion how you got out of
it you can teach other people and that
will set you up for an amazing life with
hopefully very little burnout and
definitely a lot of purpose you know i
was in thailand and i saw the golden
buddha
and the story behind the golden buddha
is they had you know the the thai people
had this priceless object
and invaders were going to come into
thailand so they got the idea to put
layers of mud over the golden buddha and
you know the invaders didn't find it
and you know many many centuries later
someone noticed this great monument of
mud
but there was gold
you know sparkling out of it and so they
went through the layers of mud and they
found the golden buddha
and i the metaphor for all your amazing
listeners and viewers is simply this
when we were born we were born into
possibility ah and wonder but through
our parents well-meaning
and the media and our teachers our
society and our peers and the social
media what happens is
we adopt the psychology of average
versus the mentality of possibility and
legendary
and as we continue to leave the
perfection of childhood
we get hurt and we get disappointed we
don't get invited to a birthday party we
lose a love we get stepped on we say i
want to be an astronaut and i want to be
a
i want to be a billionaire and i want to
also be a great chef and i want to be a
yoga teacher and our teacher or our
friend says hahaha you're a fool here's
what the 45
day quit rule is and it's hard for me i
hate this one
i look at all my big project ideas you
know i don't know about you but i have a
journal with all my big ideas in it you
know or my vision board or i have an
excel spreadsheet of all these different
ideas and projects i want to do and i've
got like you know right as an example
right now i know my next six books i'm
going to write
i know
i know my next three campaigns i'm gonna
launch
i know them
but here's what i have to force myself
to do and i don't like it
i say okay if this is a major project
that i want to do
even if it could lead to significant
growth
if i'm not going to start it listen to
this if i'm not going to start it in the
next 45 days
it's off my plate until next year
and
i push it to 2019. i literally just take
it from my journal
in my little bucket of things i want to
do this year and i put it out into 2019
and i feel
so
mentally relieved
a lot of people have a lot of anxiety
about the number of projects they have
on their plate that they really want to
do
and so what ends up happening is that
anxiety leads to a lot of
procrastination
that anxiety leads to a lot of poor
prioritization because there's so much
to do they're like oh my god there's so
much to do here so i won't do any of it
ever had that have you ever found
yourself in front of netflix going oh my
god i have so much to do but i just
watched the fourth video in the third
season has that ever happened
you have so much to and that's the
problem you have so much to do that you
haven't prioritized what you are going
to do so you don't do anything
so what i do is this time of year i look
at all those things that are on my plate
and i get honest
which ones am i going to start in the
next 45 days
and if i'm not going to start the next
45 day
put it in 2019. now it's not even on my
mental concern it's not on my dashboard
no anxiety there no my god i still got
to get that one in nope it's gone
that's the 45 day quit rule i encourage
you to challenge yourself to try it the
world that we're all living in is our
own construction and i think that's the
thing that people are missing we have
literally created this world and if this
world is delusion if this world is
destruction if this world is filled with
more bad than it is good then that is a
process of our thinking that is a
revelation
of how our minds work it is a revelation
of what we have built internally
so as leo tolstoy said everyone thinks
of changing the world but no one
thinks of changing themselves if we're
actually going to make change in the
world if those things that you have in
your mind the vision of what you want to
bring to the world all of the ills that
you want to correct if you're actually
going to correct them
you have to look inward and begin asking
how is this your responsibility what are
the things in your thinking
that have helped manifest this world
that have manifested the problems in
your own life and that will my friends i
promise you
manifest the solutions
and as stephen hawking pointed out
the greatest enemy of knowledge is not
ignorance
it's the illusion of knowledge
we think we know something that we don't
we think we have the answers we think
within us already right now or the
fundamental building blocks that we're
going to need in order to build
something new but the truth is
the only thing that we already have is
the willingness to look
the willingness to change to leverage
the things that we have but we have to
build something entirely new we have to
understand that we don't yet know enough
that we are not adequate that we have to
look at ourselves and be willing to
stare nakedly at our inadequacies and to
adjust them to fix them to not hide
behind ego to not pretend or worse
believe
that we're already who we need to be
because the only promise i can make you
is you're not yet the person you need to
be to execute to create the change that
you want to make
but i can also promise you
that you can become that
that if you're willing to do the hard
work of looking internally and building
something new if you're willing to tear
yourself down if you're willing to brick
by brick disassemble that thing that has
been built by accident inside of you and
move forward with a new level of
intention and build something an
entirely new structure with your eyes
open with embracing and accepting
a lack of knowledge but never ignorance
of not
holding on to old ideas but to ask of
everything that you choose to believe
does this move me towards my goals or
not and if it does then you do it if it
does you believe it even more but if it
doesn't right then right there you drop
it
then you make room for the new
then you can build what you want to
build
then
we'll have the change that we want when
you focus on where you want to go you
actually go towards it the more you
focus on where you want to be the more
your mind like a heat seeking missile
takes you to where you
want to be
so if you want to be an olympic athlete
you'd have to take a lot of action you
have to practice a lot and train a lot
if you don't want to do something
physical
train your mind practice with your mind
use mood boards i've done quite a few
radio interviews about why mood boards
are so successful why people
who have everything tend to have mood
boards now the mood board i made years
ago i put it above my bed
which is an odd thing to do actually
because i face away from it so i don't
look at it every day anymore but a
little while ago i looked at it and i
realized that every single thing i put
on that mood board had come true in fact
when i finished with all the um
things i was going to do as a writer i
put up some pictures one was hot air
ballooning and one was something else
and i realized that every single thing
i'd put up i think one was riding a
camel i'd actually done all of those so
i thought well i better make a new mood
board now with new things i want i wrote
down some of the countries i wanted to
go to
so if you put it above your bed do make
sure that you look at it better to put
it really on your fridge
or in your kitchen or in your office you
can also take a big photograph of it and
make that your screen saver
and the wallpaper on your phone because
then of course you will look at it every
day over and over again
but even though i made that mood board
and put it in a place where i didn't
look at it and actually looked away from
it guess what it still worked so imagine
how it will work if it's right in your
line of vision if it's on your computer
screen and i work with many many women
who are having huge problems conceiving
and i get them to make a baby board same
thing but it's a picture of a positive
pregnancy test colored into yes it's
lots of pictures of babies
i have them also put that on instagram
and on their computer screen so they see
it every day and the success rates with
using that baby board are
phenomenal
make your mood board of course you
struggle to remember it in your
day-to-day life because life is
difficult and it's harder to do things
than not to do them and it's harder to
do them well than to do them badly you
know and it's easy to sit around and be
hopeless i don't mean it's emotionally
easy because it's not
but it's procedurally easy to be useless
and to fall back into your old habits
and to not discipline yourself and
it's a matter of continual practice slow
continual practice and i think a good
example of that is something like weight
lifting you know if you start a weight
lifting program which i would recommend
by the way because it it's tremendously
advantageous physically and cognitively
you're not going to really see results
for a number of weeks and then the
results are rather slow but you can get
pretty decent results over a six-month
period and absolutely stellar results
over a couple of years and so you have
to make sure your time frame is right
and not to be too hard on yourself and i
did mention the future authoring program
um earlier
and
one of the things i would recommend too
is if you're having a hard time
implementing your
your decisions say your ethical
decisions that you spend a bit more time
thinking them through and writing them
down and the future authoring program is
really helpful for that that's why we
designed it
and so
get your goals straight and continue to
practice every day and if you're not
succeeding then make your goals slightly
smaller you want to you want to make
your goals large enough so that they
challenge you but small enough so that
you have a reasonable probability of
succeeding at them on a day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day like
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think oh my god
now i've screwed it up i've i'm not
quitting anymore you smoke a whole pack
of cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed it just means
that you had a cigarette you can start
stopping again the next day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that and so you've got to be
realistically humble you've got to be
ambitious enough in your goals so that
you're pursuing something that you
regard as truly meaningful and
worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good
um
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
when you really look at the credit it is
improved nutrition and sanitation
so people were dying of malnutrition
which made them more susceptible to
infections and other disorders and then
sanitation and vaccination that's how we
it's not antibiotics let's say it's not
pharmaceuticals it's still
conditions of living you know better
hygiene better nutrition
but now
the increment to that
is understanding what causes accelerated
aging lack of sleep
stress
unhealthy emotions like hostility and
anger and resentments and guilt and
shame and depression and anxiety lack of
mind-body coordination that's where the
yoga and the breathing techniques come
in
poor nutrition right now most of our
food
that comes
to us
at home
is manufactured refined processed
contains chemicals contains antibiotics
contains steroids because animals are
fed that and even you know there are
pesticides in the ground which are
petroleum products how does that cause
accelerated aging it causes inflammation
of something called the microbiome which
is
the genes that are in your gut which are
microbial genes
so 99
of the genetic information in your body
right now
is not human you only have one percent
of the genes in your body are from your
parents
99 of the genes in your body right now
are microbial you're a few humans i'm a
mutant i'm like an x-man
you're a few human cells hanging on to a
bacterial colony so when you put food in
your mouth the first thing that they
encounter the food encounters is these
bacterial genes and if your food is
inflamed then the bacterial genes get
inflamed causes inflammation in the body
you get metabolites
that are called cytokines there's lots
of complexity i think the thing that
people misunderstand about success
is
they're looking for the easiest way to
get there
you know and it's funny
how many people
books have you read or
i won't say promoted but had on your
show and everybody goes
five easy steps
ten steps to greatness yeah you know
eight steps to this and
those steps for success they're infinite
they are
infinite you cannot
count them
it doesn't matter how long you've been
doing it those steps are constantly
shifting
you don't know if they're there
sometimes you have to trust that the
next step is going to be there when you
can't even see it and sometimes when you
step on that step you go right into
quicksand but you got to be able to
pull yourself back out of it again so
everybody's looking for these steps and
there are no steps so steps never never
end and you just can't climb steps
sometimes you got to crawl though those
steps and you finally get to the top
and everything shifts and you're at the
bottom it's crazy
all right what is that what does that
mean sometimes you're at the top and
then you're at the bottom again well you
may get to the top and you're like i'm
here
and then you look back down and you look
up again you're actually on the first
step
you're on the first step again
and where you thought was the top is not
even the top it's the beginning wow it's
literally the beginning
of where you're supposed to be
and that's when most people just quit it
i just like it just drives me crazy
because everybody's like here
look at
i always people that i do the interview
with i always like to use them as an
example because people can relate to
that all right
you've been climbing steps for how long
to get to here
to get i mean since starting this it's
been over eight years but the journey
before then
it was you know decades to build myself
to prepare myself for this and now i
feel like i'm just getting started right
exactly so you have
right exactly so all the steps that you
climbed just to get started yeah
just to get started and people don't
want to talk about those steps they
don't want to talk about those steps and
how difficult those steps are and how
many steps that you stumbled on and how
many steps you didn't even see and how
many steps that people placed in front
of you and they pulled and they pulled
them off pulled away people that you
were very close to people that you knew
right that people that you thought that
were like hey these people actually have
my back except yeah they did have you
back but they were actually pushing you
down the steps
yes
no and
it's funny when you talk about those
things or people talk about it they seem
surprised but you should know that in
that path all those things are going to
be there how many people do you know
maybe even you
have a job that just kills you it's
draining your energy you hate going
there maybe even a company that you
started that you thought was going to be
exciting but just it's just robbing the
life out of you or even school maybe
you're in college or even high school
and and it's just
every moment of it is frustrating and
here's what we do we think to ourselves
when i get out of this job and i start
my own company then i'm going to be
fired up then i'm going to be excited
then i'm going to take my life to the
next level when i get out of school i'm
going to do it when i when i throw this
company away and i start the new company
and guess what that's the worst thinking
that type of thinking will keep you
exactly where you are so let me just
give you an example
i don't know if you know this about me
but when i was in my teens and my 20s i
worked on cars every single day of my
life i had a collision repair shop i i
got wrecked cars and people brought them
in and i fixed them i sucked fumes every
day i had dirt under my nails every
night i was literally scraping under my
nails trying to get piles of dirt out i
changed motors i did i rebuilt
carburetors i mean the worst thing i
hated was painting the cars because i
got such a headache even though we had
good ventilation i'd get such a headache
from the fumes but that's what i did did
i love painting cars
no i absolutely despised it i hated
every bit of it but i was lucky enough
to realize
that
how you do any job is how you do every
job
and what i had to do was find things
that were exciting in that job because i
knew it was the stepping stone so here's
what i believe so many people hate what
they do their lack of energy when you
don't like something you're not
enthusiastic you're not excited you're
not nice to people so you're just
thinking i'm gonna get in this groove
but then something's gonna snap and then
all of a sudden i'm gonna be amazing i'm
gonna be excited i'm gonna i'm gonna
find that new job that nuclear no you
have to start now so what you have to do
like i did with the collision shop is
you have to find a way for that dull job
that thing that robs your energy now to
be exciting yes you do as hard as that
sounds do it to the best of your ability
and guess what opportunity comes along
in places you won't even realize
that there isn't even there's an
opportunity for you example so i'm in
the car business hating it but i found a
way to be enthusiastic because what i
liked is i like the fact that a car
would come in wrecked i could visualize
it looking perfect again and visualize
how excited the person would be to get
their car back to to new so when i was
working on cars i didn't think oh i got
bondo on my fingertips paint on my nails
i got a headache from the fumes i'm
dirty it's sweaty if i thought about
that everything would have sucked but
what i thought about was how excited the
person's gonna be when they see their
car back to normal and i found a way to
be enthusiastic and excited if you asked
anybody like that guy loves collision
work
it's not true i wasn't lying i found a
way to manipulate myself so
in that instance my first big real
estate deal i did several with no money
down worked right my butt off to to get
it done but my first big real estate
deal that after years uh was the first
deal i did over a million dollars on
true story in my little town in upstate
new york a town called marlborough new
york
and guess who i did the deal with
somebody who came into the collision
shop and i did work on their car lent me
the money because i was so enthusiastic
so excited such in a good mood the guy's
like how do you have so much energy how
are you so excited i said well this is
just a stepping stone for me i'm working
on real estate deals i've done a few and
working on this bigger one he's like
well why aren't you doing the big one
i'm like i'm trying to put the money
together but i'll get it i know i'll
make it that guy lent me
80 000
just like that and he made a ton of
money for it i mean i i was so
appreciative of the loan he gave me i
did everything in my power to make sure
that deal the problem is shutting down
emotionally
if you stop learning
emotional learning stops when you shut
down
so you shut down to protect yourself
but for development you need
vulnerability vulnerability from the
latin word vulnerary vulnerary the wound
so vulnerabilities are capacity to be
wounded
and nothing grows when it's not
vulnerable
a tree doesn't grow where it's hard and
thick it goes where it's soft and green
and vulnerable a crustacean animal like
a crab cannot grow
encased in a hard shell to grow
it has to mold make itself soft and
vulnerable same with children
when children shut down emotionally
they have difficulty learning especially
from negative experience
so they keep repeating the same stuff
over and over again and despite the
negative consequences they learn nothing
from it
and then the adult gets exasperated
i've told him a thousand times not to do
it and you're still doing it
well the proper response is
if you've told him a thousand times
and he's still doing it who's got the
learning problem here
clearly what clearly what we have to do
clearly what we have to do is we have to
find out what's going on we notice that
some people seem to want to hang on to
stuff that is bothering them they're
forever talking about it they don't want
to let it go they've had a a failure at
something and it's drilling they can't
get over it they just can't get over or
somebody said something nasty to them
they don't want to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
i don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
[Music]
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows
the only thing that can grow is the
thing you give energy to
why would you hold on to anything that's
not serving you now i want you to think
about this i'm not going to talk about a
lot about this today because i don't
think i have to i just want to let you
know that if you're holding on to
something that does not serve you
you are making a terrible error it's
going to cause all kinds of problems you
may blame other people or other things
you may blame the situation
it's you are the cause of the problem
the man that told me to pick up this
book and read it ray stanford
he had a saying he used to say to me
bob you're the only problem you'll ever
have and you're the only solution
i think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but i do
understand it
and you know something
i am the only problem i'll ever have and
i am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you reject it
you know the beautiful part about having
an inductive reasoning factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you i talk to so many smart
fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids and they're right out
of college they're in their entry-level
jobs and i'll ask them how's it going
and they'll say
i think i'm gonna quit
and i'm like why
they say to me
i'm not making an impact
i'm like you know you've been here eight
months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired i mean it was mutual
or they're quitting because they're not
making an impact or they're not finding
the thing they're looking for they're
not feeling fulfilled as if it's a
scavenger hunt love
a job you
find joy from
is not something you discover it's not
like i found love
here it is i found a job i love that's
not how it works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work very
hard every single day of your life to
stay in love you find a job that brings
you ultimate joy because you work hard
every single day to serve those around
you and you maintain that joy it's not a
discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain they
know exactly what they want they can see
the summit what they can't see is the
mountain
this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what i'm
talking about
take a helicopter climb i don't care but
there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is
this entire generation has an
institutionalized sense of impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled or do they just quit and on to
the next dumping on to the next
ghost and on to the next and i at the
time this was early on you know because
when i first started making money and it
was you know my salary
or my earnings
were
published all over the place i mean the
first year i was like really did i make
that much money oh my god um
it was very difficult for me to figure
out where my boundaries were
because i'd grown up poor and didn't
have anything
so it's easy when you don't have
anything and people ask you for money
they say i need 500 you say i don't have
it because i'm just trying to get my
rent paid
it's harder when your
multi-billion dollar salary is now in
the paper and you get a lot of friends
and cousins you didn't have before
so how do you set
boundaries for yourself i was having
trouble setting boundaries myself for
myself for even strangers people would
just show up at my door in chicago and
say oh bro i left my husband please help
me and i would because she knows i
haven't
so
don't try that now though okay
don't try that now i figured it out
what i learned was is that
oh the reason why people keep showing up
is because my intention is to make them
think that i'm such a nice person
that
you can ask me for anything
you can get me to do anything i'm going
to say yes i'm going to say yes so when
stevie called me this time i thought i'd
try out my first no on stevie let's
start big
he wanted me to donate some money to a
charity and i didn't want to donate to
the charity
because
i have my own charities and i care about
a lot of people but the problem is when
you you have money everybody thinks you
just want to give to everything so every
letter i ever get starts with we know
you love the children
yes i do love the children but somebody
else is going to have to help the
children
so i said to stevie uh i said to stevie
no
and um
as a person who has that disease to
please i was waiting for him then just
to say
i will never speak to you again
i will never call you i will never sing
a song for you
and he didn't he just said okay
okay
okay it's okay he said okay check you
later
and
[Music]
what i learned from that is
many times you will have angst and worry
about things
and
put yourself in a state like someone
said this morning because their phone
went off they were mortified over a
phone i said really
you will put yourself in a state when
the other person really isn't even
thinking about you
so
learning that i could specifically
determine for myself what the boundaries
were for me
what i wanted to do
give my money give my time give of my
service to who i wanted to give it to
when i did that i get to make that
decision and just because you get a
hundred requests a week doesn't mean you
have to try to fulfill all of that just
because you have all of these demands on
your time and on you doesn't mean that
you have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul as william
ernest henley said in invictus and
understanding that really changed the
meaning of my life in that i was not no
longer driven by what
other people wanted me to do
but took charge of my own destiny making
choices based upon what do i feel
is the next right move for me for those
of you that feel very overwhelmed
because of home work side hustle
and you're a woman
you probably also feel guilty about
taking time to work on your side hustle
that's because women girls we are raised
to be good girls we're raised to be good
daughters we're raised to
be seen and not heard we're raised to
take care of people it's socialized into
you and you see your mothers by the way
also sacrifice everything to take care
of everybody else and to put themselves
laps this is a learned behavior so if
you
also are a woman you probably feel
guilty for taking time for yourself
stop that you have to stop that
the reason why you have to stop that is
first of all if you're a mom you've got
to show your daughters and your sons
what it looks like to pursue your dreams
secondly
as a woman you're not going to get what
you want if you're constantly putting
guilt on yourself for taking time for
yourself and third the only way you will
discover the power and potential inside
of you is if you push that generation
to the side and you actually realize
that your life is for you that your mom
you know why she sacrificed everything
she did because she wanted you
to pursue your dreams so knock it off
with the guilt because the guilt is also
contributing to the overwhelm the guilt
is making you not talk to your partner
or your boss or your colleagues or your
friends about what you need for support
the guilt is adding weight to
you not being able to carve out the time
and be disciplined
to find the time for yourself and so it
has got to go you hear me get rid of it
i have have a son who suffers from a
mental illness bipolar
and many times like during this period
in the last few months he
has decided he didn't want to take his
medication i don't care how old your
kids
become he's 35 they're always your
children so not only does it keep me up
at night
but it keeps me singing a song you about
to make me lose my mind up in here up in
here you've got to make me hack the food
up in here
i remember one night somebody called me
say are you on facebook i said no
go to yourself facebook and here they're
saying
i've spent more money on marijuana than
i have or self-development i'm mrs mamie
brown's grandson
let me tell you something
i needed some weed after watching him
so you know the life said fake it not
strange that you have faced a fiery
furnaces in this world
it has been a humbling experience that
i've been able to
motivate and inspire
young men around the world and my son
looked like i had him by myself that i
can't reach you
and so
i have learned lord brought me the
serenity to accept the things that i
cannot change i can't change him the
courage to change the things that i can
i can change how i react how i respond
and the courage to know the difference
and so
i've learned to discipline myself to let
go and let god and once letting go don't
go back to god and get it just give it
to it
yes yes that our kids come through us
but they come from god and learn to
surrender life is about surrendering
and releasing
and i've learned the discipline to do
that
because it hasn't been easy i have
several people in my life friends and
relatives who i want to support but
after i spend time with them i feel
drained
sometimes i avoid them but then i feel
guilty and can only avoid them for so
long
can you explain why i feel this way and
what advice you have for me
thank you for your question erica and i
think this is something that a lot of
people face and are not sure how to
approach
basically i mean the way to look at it
is that we only have so much energy each
day when we go to sleep we wake up in
the morning we have for example this
much energy and throughout the day we we
use that energy we give that energy to
people and things around us and by the
end of the day that energy gets less and
less and less and then until the end of
the day where there's
almost nothing left and you feel tired
and you go to sleep again one of the
things you have to understand is that
some people fill you with energy and
some people drain you of energy the
people that drain you of energy i like
to call them energy vampires and there
are a lot of them and sometimes these
people are colleagues their
friends their relatives even close
family members one of the important
things to do is really identify if
someone is a temporary energy vampire or
are they inherently an energy vampire so
what i mean by that is someone is
temporarily an energy vampire i mean
that
they're going through a difficult time
in their life their somebody in the
family has died or going through the law
so some big challenging experience and
for a few months or
maybe a couple of years they're
energetically draining but it's okay you
know you love them to your friend their
family member you want to support them
and you can put up with that for a
little time in your life
but someone is inherently an energy
vampire you know they've always been
their whole life every time you meet
with them you encounter them you feel
completely drained then it's really
important to take note of that that's a
personality trait that's not going to
change anytime soon unless they're
actively working on it
and most energetic most energy vampires
don't really want to work on themselves
in nature
so one of the things to do here at this
point is to
identify these people one of the ways to
identify these people is that when you
spend time with someone
and as soon as you have a conversation
with them after spending time with them
when you walk away as soon as you turn
around and walk away ask yourself do you
feel uplifted or do you feel drained
and that's
immediately you'll know as soon as you
turn around and walk like you feel
uplifted you'll go like wow that was
such a great conversation i got so much
out of it i feel so inspired you know
then that person uplifted you but if you
walk away and you feel completely
drained and going oh my god that was so
exhausting then
chances are that person has an energy
vampire and especially if you meet that
person 15 20 times a year and just so
you met the person 20 times a year and
out of that 20 times a year 19 of those
were extremely exhausting conversations
then
you can quite very well qualified you
can easily qualify that that person is
an energy vampire and you want to avoid
them you don't really want people in
your life the way to look at it is that
if you're working so hard on yourself
to improve yourself to be a better
person then why allow someone else to
come and dream your way it's for example
an entrepreneur who built his business
from nothing
would never allow somebody to come in
and destroy his business before i start
this journey be navy seal i go back to
see my dad because i realize now i gotta
fix some
i'm blaming everything
i gotta go back you know how a lot of
times like
if you're a runner you're you're you're
your right knee may hurt but it's not
your right knee that hurts it's really
your left hip yes but we're constantly
on the right knee
i'm concentrating on all my
but i need to go back to the root of the
problem which is my dad
i gotta face the demon
i gotta go back and see what made him so
[ __ ] up to make me so why am i [ __ ]
up mm-hmm
so i go back and i and i go back in as a
as an older man now i'm in my 20s i'm
not a kid anymore and i want to see this
man and face him as a as a as a grown
man
but still as a kid in my head i was
still a kid but i was a grown man as my
age
i went back and i realized he was the
same man that he was still the same
still the same
and i talked to him he was still nuts
and um
but i i had to go back and face that one
more time but to face it in a different
way how'd you do it differently
i looked at him in a way we never said
sorry to one another and he went off
about my mom and my grandparents and all
kind of i looked at them in a way
that i realized now
why you [ __ ] this up
i had to almost be him
to realize it's okay brother
it's okay because i realized that
somewhere in your life
something [ __ ] you up
and you didn't deal with it
and so you put it on me my mom and
everybody around you
i'm going to deal with my
wow so even though you gave me all this
you you gave me a satchel that i didn't
deserve and now i'm all [ __ ] up and
people think i'm a liar and i'm all
[ __ ] up you gave me this you created
this nightmare of goggins
i'm gonna fix it though your real self
knows the truth no matter what mask or
what face you wear in the world your
real self knows the truth and there was
a time in my life when i acted like i
knew a truth that i didn't know and the
truth i didn't know
was the depth of my value and my worth
you see i had already been an author
that had sold over 6 million books
14 different titles i had already been
on my own television show i had traveled
around the world i had spoken to
hundreds of thousands of people and
still i did not know or value
my own worth so in a very big
opportunity to go forward and to be on
what was once called the oprah winfrey
show
yes and i went on the oprah winfrey show
and miss winfrey asked me back again and
again and again and eventually i became
part of her change your life faculty and
it was all good i had written 13 books i
had traveled all over the country i had
done her show repeatedly but i didn't
know
my own sense of worth
so what happened i tried to live in a
place that i didn't believe was true for
me and eventually i crashed and burned
crashed and burned by leaving the oprah
winfrey show and going on to another
network and doing another show that
didn't even survive a season all because
i didn't know
my work now it would have looked like
all sorts of external circumstances oh
there was a miscommunication between me
and miss winfrey and the other network
was offering me a lot of money and why
shouldn't i take a big business deal no
it was about me not knowing my own worth
me not being able to stand
in the miracle
of being on the oprah winfrey show
repeatedly among honored teachers
without having to work hard for it
because that was what i had been taught
the matter with me was that i didn't
know how to receive a gift a blessing
without working hard for it so when
things came to me easily i blew them up
it's self-sabotage or procrastination or
forgetting or whatever it is that
opportunity went away because i didn't
know my work that's the kind of truth we
have to tell each other we have to be
aware of it we have to acknowledge it
and we have to accept it and then we
have to look at what makes me
live less than my truth
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want even more habits of insanely
productive people check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there bruce lee said if you value your
life you will value your time because
time is what makes up your life so let's
talk about
the the concept of how to achieve